hi I'm Ryan hi my name is Mary black
she's very prepared mm-hmm very prepared
to say that all right people this is my
sister Mary black right she's really
nervous to be here I had to convince her
to come on all my life I've been
convincing girls this is such a struggle
I know why I'm attracted to girls I
gotta convince because my family's like
that he always got to convince them for
something they're the hardest crowd to
you I just showed them this the short
film I did with Sally single girl on
Valentine's Day I showed them the
multiple Clips one and yeah the room was
not filled with laughter at that moment
they are the toughest crowd I just want
to get my sister some advice just
remember there's gonna be at least
hundreds of people watching this video
yeah hundreds I'm sometimes thousands
and don't worry about YouTube haters
because they exist but they're just
jealous and fat anyway we're both half
Filipino
so we're gonna do what family does best
and what Filipinos do best which is show
our love for other Filipinos and we're
gonna watch the Manny Pacquiao
documentary now my sister's in it not
the documentary we're gonna watch the
trailer for the documentary now if my
sisters like me she would know to get
more in the shot we don't know [ __ ]
about him really do you I need to feed
it a British guy mm-hmm that's pretty
good it's pretty good I saw him beat up
like a Hispanic guy once this wasn't at
the boxing ring now you're probably
thinking no don't you question my
judgment you are younger than me all
right time to get our Pacquiao fighting
skills on or something cool when I was a
boy I had to fight to feed my family
I miss out my entire life I fought to
survive
my only hope inspiring Wow if you're a
fighter
truly a fighter you fight again big
smile and he's waving at everybody you
never know Muhammad Ali's gonna walk to
your door this little Filipino kid comes
up to me and I should walk in this kid
fight Manny Pacquiao is the best thing
that ever happened to me
is the best thing happen often Manny
Pacquiao has always been a fighter but
it's his life story that made him famous
in sports it's on the cover of Time
magazine
60 minutes late night he's just
transcended himself and made that
crossover away from boxing the question
is always what is the bridge too far
form you've got boxing you've got
politics and then you've got your people
of Salonga what priority are you gonna
give them things they can plumb in your
life is definitely beyond just this
boxing ring it's bigger than boxing it's
bigger than being a prizefighter his
journey now is about fighting and
winning for people
pretty accepts it
why do I bounce
why do I fight
because it's nuts when many coming soon
okay so that Pacquiao movie thoughts
none no thoughts just some Filipino guy
just some Filipino guy that's how you
view it we have a bond now she's the
coolest younger sister in the world
she is she can do art that's really
awesome you know a lot of ways Manny
Pacquiao's an artist I guess it's a
Filipino thing you think Manny Pacquiao
sings karaoke every Filipino is a singer
that's true that's true
including this guy check this [ __ ] out I
can show you the world take you wonder
by whether those lyrics I don't know no
no I
Aladin kind of looks Filipino we can
probably be for Indian we're a bunch of
races I'll be cool will you say we're a
bunch of racist races a races you give
me Burt black we probably are we're half
Italian Sicilian actually and I've seen
true romance and Dennis Hopper gives a
powerful speech about how all Sicilians
have a little bit of black in them no
Liam you don't give us a speech oh he
knows Filipinos are awesome do you think
Manny Pacquiao is really good at math
okay just because we're Asian doesn't
mean we're all good at math oh do you
think he uses recycling bins but instead
of a recycling bin he uses like a target
bag to recycle